وبالحديث عن مدمرات لا تقتصر صناعتها او
ملكيتها على الولايات المتحده والصين فقط
بل ان بعض الدول تنافسها في الجوده
لنستعرض معكم اهم هذه المدمرات اولا مدمره
الكوريه الجنوبيه هي شبيهه بطراز 055
الصينيه
حوالي 10 الى 12 الف طن هي اصغر قليلا من
شبيهتها الصينيه لكنها تتفوق عليها بقوه
النيران مع 128 خليه واسلحه تشمل صواريخ
ارض جو مضاده للغواصات وصواريخ ايضا كروز
ايضا لدينا مدمره مايا اليابانيه وهي احدى
افضل المدمرات عالميا مسلحه بسته وتسعين
خليه في ال اس ويمكنها اطلاق كل صواريخ
المضاده للصواريخ البالسيه والصواريخ
المضاده للغواصات تمتلك ايضا اجهزه
استشعار وانظمه خاصه متطوره جدا ولدي
القدره على تدمير الصواريخ الباليسيه التي
تنتقل خارج الغلاف الجوي للارض وده
يابانيه اخرى وهي مدمره موغامي هي سفينه
حربيه سريعه تزن
5500 طن مع سته عشره خليه وتطلق بالسواريخ
ارض جو ايضا صواريخ مضاده للسفن
ما قلته في الاسابيع الماضيه وخاصه في
اليومين الماضيين لقد عبرت عن قلقي بشان
السلوك غير المسؤول الذي رايناه مع عمليات
الاعتراض القريبه وبينما كنا قادمين رايت
مثالا على احدى طائراتنا التي اعترضتها
احدى طائراتهم على مسافه خطيره للغايه وفي
اليوم الاخير فقط راينا حادثه اخرى حيث
عبرت احدى سفنهم امام احدى سفننا ربما
تكون هناك 150 قدما او شيء من هذا القبيل
وهذا امر خطير للغايه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات